(electronic dance music)
- I mean listen,
- I love Avicii
- [man] Oh, yeah.
as much as the next person,
but I did not pay $5 for that remix.
- Wait, but you know what I'd pay like
a billion dollars for?
Like some tacos!
( blonde woman gasps)
- I've literally never been
this hungry in my life.
Where should we go?
- (simultaneously) Taco Bell!
- Let's go!
- [man] Ok. Wait! Your shoes.
- God, I got them. Let's go!
- [man] Are you barefoot?
- I like shoes not so much today.
Oh my God. Taco Bell delivers?
- Yes! What do you want?
- Ok, let me tell you.
I would like a Beefy Five-Layer Burrito,
and a Crunchwrap Supreme Beef.
Thank you so much. Bye, Felicity Hoffman.
- I don't know how you wore
those around all night.
- You don't anything about my life.
- Taco Bell! Taco Bell! Wait!
Thank you so much!
- Was that an angel?
- Who?
No, that's just Taco Bell.
Oh my God. We got so much.
- Ohhh!
- It's... what?
- I'm so happy.
- I know. Me, too.
- What do you want?
(loud restaurant chatter)
- Can I have an Italian sub
with chicken tenders, and French fries,
and mozzarella sticks, please?
Do you want anything?
- They make that here?
- Yeah.
- I'll have that.
How can they put this all
in a sandwich?
Can I have two eggs over-easy,
with a side of bacon,
and one pancake over-easy?
Thank you so much.
- A chicken pot-pie, please. Too.
- Kenny!
- [Kenny] Also. What?
- Do you think she knew I was drunk?
- [Kenny] No, of course not.
Waiter! More spoons, please!
- [woman] Please. (gasps)
Speaking of spoons.
Do you know what I just got a craving for?
- Tell me.
- Ok.
- Four words. Movie camera. (mumbles)
7-Eleven!
- (screams excitedly)
- [Kenny] Yes!
(dramatic hip hop music)
(Kenny vomiting)
- [blonde woman] You ok?
- Mhmm.
- How do you feel?
- I feel like...
I want hot dogs.
(dramatic hip hop music)
- [Kenny] Can we go home?
- [blonde woman] Yeah.
Can you pull over right
here, sir? This is me.
- Wait, this is In-N-Out.
- Yeah. I'll see you tomorrow, Kenny.
- [Kenny] Get me a burger or something.
A Double Double,
with extra onions.
And the secret sauce.